hey you are so beautiful  you don't even know you should take  pictures $500 snuff a lot of money for  life more confident gorgeous I don't  want you taking pictures with Vaughn  anymore you should make up your mind  another nice sky  someday you're gonna meet the perfect  person so a lot of what we do here is  fetish fetish is not about sex it's  about power play  so would you feel comfortable playing  the top and bottom just do it really  slow entertain us naughty girl  we could try to get turned on your work  of art mom I told you the temp in  accounting for him pray for the money  dress coded big salary huh I think it  might be a bad person a bad person I  think you're a beautiful person  there's nowhere like this in Long Beach  of course there is you just have to know  where to look I think it's most  beautiful  my mom doesn't play video  I exist  person and she doesn't find me back  ready to do this  you